It happened a long time ago and Jonathan didn't really think about it anymore. It was over, as far as he was concerned, high school stuff.
那件事发生在很久以前，乔纳森（Jonathan）已经不再去想它了。在他看来，那都已经过去了，不过是些高中时代的陈年往事。
I was cello player. Every high school has the nerdy, soft kid who brings his cello to class, and that would have been me.
我曾经是个大提琴手。每所高中都有那种书呆子气、性格软弱的孩子，会背着大提琴去上课，那个人就是我。
Every high school also has bullies, and there was one guy who picked on Jonathan. Jonathan remembers him as a glad-hander, somebody with lots of friends. And also--
每所高中也都有霸凌者，当时有个家伙总是欺负乔纳森。乔纳森记得他是个左右逢源的人，朋友很多。而且——
A jock. He hung out in the weight room. He squatted something over 500 pounds when he was in high school.
是个体育健将。他经常泡在健身房里。他在高中时深蹲就能举起500多磅。
And you actually know the number?
你居然还记得具体的数字？
I believe it was 510 pounds, a number that I remember almost 30 years later.
我记得应该是510磅，这个数字我至今还记得，尽管已经过去快30年了。
Because everybody knew the number.
因为每个人都知道这个数字。
Because everybody knew this. I remember him, but I would be very surprised if he remembered me. he was the sort of person who would walk across the street to be unpleasant to somebody. Or, in my most notable instance, I was walking down the hall to history class, and he hip-checked me. I was carrying my cello. I went sailing down the stairs with my cello. You'd be surprised how many times a cello in its case can bounce.
因为每个人都知道这件事。我记得他，但我敢肯定，如果他还记得我，那一定会让我很惊讶。他那种人，为了去刁难别人，甚至愿意特意穿过马路。或者，就像我经历过最典型的一次，我正走在去历史课的走廊上，他用髋部撞了我一下。当时我正抱着大提琴。我连人带琴滚下了楼梯。你可能会惊讶，装在大提琴盒里的大提琴竟然能弹跳那么多次。
It was a lot of money in repairs. He was laughing about it to his friends. I suspect he forgot about it five minutes later. I didn't.
修理费花了不少钱。他还在那儿笑着跟朋友吹嘘。我猜他五分钟后就忘了。但我没有。
And so who was he? Who was this guy?
那么他是谁呢？那个家伙是谁？
That guy was Jack Abramoff.
那个人是杰克·阿布拉莫夫（Jack Abramoff）。
Jack Abramoff. Remember him? Big time lobbyist, pled guilty to multiple criminal felonies, now in prison, one of the poster boys in our congressional corruption scandals. Jack Abramoff.
杰克·阿布拉莫夫。还记得他吗？那个重量级的游说者，对多项重罪认罪，现在在监狱里，是我们国会腐败丑闻中的典型人物。杰克·阿布拉莫夫。
It's just beautiful. It's more than I could have wished for.
这真是太美妙了。这比我所能奢望的还要好。
Well, in a certain sense, thanks to justice department prosecutors, finally someone gets revenge on him.
嗯，从某种意义上说，多亏了司法部的检察官，终于有人替我向他复仇了。
It's sort of sweet, isn't it? And to realize that it's the same person was sort of strange. It's like finding out years later that the person that punched you really hard in elementary school and made you cry ended up being the heavyweight champion of the world.
这感觉有点甜蜜，不是吗？意识到那竟然是同一个人，感觉真的很奇妙。就像多年后发现，小学时那个狠狠揍你一顿让你哭鼻子的家伙，最终成了世界重量级冠军一样。
Jonathan says that he had this feeling of, I knew it. I knew that guy was bad. And yes, it is petty to feel vindicated about that feeling so many years later. And yes, there is no dignity to that feeling. But there you have it.
乔纳森说他当时就有种“我早就知道”的感觉。我就知道那家伙不是好东西。是的，在这么多年后为那种预感感到释怀确实显得有些心胸狭隘。而且，这种感觉也并不怎么光彩。但事实就是这样。
Who wouldn't feel satisfied that he was getting his comeuppance?
谁会不对他得到报应感到满足呢？
This is so typical. We think the past is over. We're not thinking about the past, we're having no feelings about the past at all, and then a name pops up from years before, and suddenly we realize our old feelings are just sitting there, dormant, intact, recognizable, ready to be revived, like cavemen thawed from frozen arctic ices, as you know that often happens. Jonathan Gold went on to become a newspaper writer, the restaurant critic for the LA Weekly . He won a Pulitzer Prize this year, and he's going to his 30th high school reunion this weekend.
这太典型了。我们以为过去已经结束了。我们不去想过去，对过去没有任何感觉，然后一个多年前的名字突然冒出来，我们突然意识到，我们旧时的情感依然驻扎在那里，蛰伏着，完整如初，清晰可辨，随时准备复苏——就像从北极冰层中解冻的穴居人，你知道，这种事经常发生。乔纳森·高德（Jonathan Gold）后来成为了一名报纸撰稿人，《洛杉矶周刊》的餐厅评论家。他今年获得了普利策奖，这个周末他要去参加高中30周年同学会。
When we tried to reach Jack Abramoff for a comment, his spokesman Harry [? Cohen ?] sent us this statement. "This story is not true. Mr. Abramoff does not know Mr. Gold. And he has no idea why Mr. Gold would fabricate such a story. There is no point in commenting further on something that never happened." Gold says he stands by his story.
当我们试图联系杰克·阿布拉莫夫请他置评时，他的发言人哈里·科恩（Harry Cohen）给我们发来了这份声明：“这个故事不是真的。阿布拉莫夫先生不认识高德先生。他也不知道高德先生为什么要捏造这样一个故事。对于一件从未发生过的事情，没有必要再做任何评论。”高德表示他坚持自己的说法。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. Today on our program, It's Never Over, stories of stuff that will not end. Act One of our show today, Who Takes the Class Out of Class Reunion. Mr. Jon Ronson demonstrates what can possibly happen when you have a keen sense of injustice that will not end. Act Two, Life Without Leanne, Larry Doyle and a love that will not end. Act Three, Deal of a Lifetime, a real estate transaction that will not end. Act Four, One Word: Timing, a joke that will not go away, and what can happen when you hold onto a joke for years before you can find a conversation where you can say that joke out loud. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》（This American Life）节目，由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。今天节目的主题是“永不结束”（It's Never Over），讲述那些永远不会结束的事情。今天的第一幕，《谁让同学会不再是同学会》。乔恩·罗森（Jon Ronson）展示了当你拥有一种永不磨灭的强烈正义感时，可能会发生什么。第二幕，《没有莉安的生活》（Life Without Leanne），拉里·多伊尔（Larry Doyle）和一份永不终结的爱。第三幕，《终身契约》（Deal of a Lifetime），一笔永不终结的房地产交易。第四幕，《一个词：时机》（One Word: Timing），一个挥之不去的笑话，以及当你把一个笑话憋在心里多年，直到能找到合适的谈话场合才说出来，会发生什么。敬请收听。
Act One, Who Takes the Class Out of Class Reunion. Well, Jon Ronson has been on our show a number of times. He's written several books in England where he lives. He's on television doing these funny and also rather revealing documentary stories on Channel Four. And you might think that, with all that success, he'd be feeling pretty good about things. Well, you'd be wrong.
第一幕，谁让同学会不再是同学会。嗯，乔恩·罗森上过我们节目很多次了。他在他居住的英国写过好几本书。他在第四频道主持那些既有趣又颇具启发性的纪录片。你可能会想，既然取得了这么多成就，他应该对现状感觉很不错。好吧，那你就错了。
I wake up in the middle of the night. I find I'm still angry with the boys who threw me into Roath Park Lake in Cardiff in the summer of 1983 when I was 16. I log onto Friends Reunited. I find one of them, and email to inform him that I'm now a best selling author. He emails me back. He says that the reason why they did it was because I was a pain in the ass. He says the tenor of my email leads him to suspect that I haven't changed, and that throwing me in the lake again today would be an appropriate response. I email him back to say I earn more money than he does. He hasn't yet emailed me back. Touche.
我会在半夜惊醒。我发现自己依然对1983年夏天我16岁时，把我扔进卡迪夫罗斯公园湖（Roath Park Lake）的那帮男孩感到愤怒。我登录了“重聚的朋友”（Friends Reunited）网站。我找到了其中一个人，发邮件通知他我现在是一位畅销书作家。他给我回了封邮件。他说他们当时那么做是因为我是一个“彻头彻尾的讨厌鬼”。他说我的邮件语气让他怀疑我根本没变，而且今天再把我扔进湖里也是一种合适的应对。我回邮件告诉他我赚的钱比他多。他到现在还没回我。触及痛处了吧。
I told my friend Graham Linehan about the time I was thrown in the lake, and it turns out he's got a story just like mine. Graham wrote Father Ted , which was Britain's biggest comedy show for 10 years. Graham's a big success, but he says he can't stop dwelling on a few weeks he spent in France one summer 20 years ago with a boy called Christoph.
我告诉我的朋友格拉汉姆·莱恩汉（Graham Linehan）关于我被扔进湖里的事，结果发现他也有类似的经历。格拉汉姆写了《弗雷德神父》（Father Ted），这是英国十年来最火的喜剧节目。格拉汉姆是个大成功者，但他却说他无法停止纠结于20年前一个夏天他在法国与一个叫克里斯托弗（Christoph）的男孩共度的几周。
He was my French correspondent.
他是你的法国笔友？
Exchange student?
交换生？
Yeah. So I went to his place for two weeks, got to know him, and then, just a gradual thing, just realized after a couple of days that he didn't like me at all.
对。所以我去了他家住了两周，开始了解他，然后，这是一种循序渐进的感觉，过了几天我就意识到他根本不喜欢我。
How did you first spot that?
你是怎么发现的？
He was talking to his parents, and he was saying-- even though I couldn't understand French, he was always saying, quoi, quoi? I was like an Irish Manuel. I was basically walking around going, quoi? every time anyone said. It was the only word I could understand. So I could sense he didn't really like me. And he was too mature for me, so rather than placing me with, say, a nerd who loves Dungeons and Dragons , who I'd still be friends with now if I'd met him, they place me with a bloke who got a motorcycle for his birthday.
他当时在和他父母谈话，他在说——即使我听不懂法语，但他总是在说“quoi, quoi?”（什么，什么？）。我就像爱尔兰版的曼努埃尔（Manuel）。基本上每当有人说话时，我就在旁边走来走去说着“什么？”。这是我唯一能听懂的词。所以我能感觉到他并不怎么喜欢我。而且他对我来说太成熟了，所以他们没有把我安排给那种比如热爱《龙与地下城》的书呆子——如果我遇到那样的人，我们现在还会是朋友——而是把我安排给了一个生日收到摩托车作为礼物的大块头。
And you began to get the sense that he didn't like you.
你开始感觉到他不喜欢你了。
No, he didn't. You're constantly the subject of jokes, and I had a terrible time, really miserable. And he was a horrible bully, and his friends all hated me, and I nearly had a fight with one of his friends in his school. And then he was going to come over to Ireland, so I just thought, well, he'll be on my home ground, I'll have a bit of control. It won't be so bad this time. So we'll see what happens next. So he came to Ireland, and he just had complete control over my life in Ireland as well. He was immediately friends with all the cool kids in my school, and he was just horrible. He beat me up in the swimming pool with his friend once. It was just a complete nightmare.
没错，他就是不喜欢。你一直是他取笑的对象，我当时过得非常糟糕，真的很痛苦。他是一个可怕的恶霸，他的朋友们也都讨厌我，我差点在他学校和他朋友打起来。后来他要来爱尔兰，所以我想，好吧，他在我的主场，我会有一点控制权。这次应该不会那么糟了。所以我们看看接下来发生了什么。他到了爱尔兰，结果他同样完全控制了我在爱尔兰的生活。他立刻和我学校里所有酷小孩成了朋友，他还是那么恶劣。有一次他和他的朋友在游泳池里打了我。那简直是一场彻底的噩梦。
This odd hell that childhood is, where you can be going through something in very close proximity to your parents, and they still can't help you. You still can't really tell anyone about it. It's obsessed me, not just him, but generally that problem of childhood.
童年那种奇怪的地狱，你可能就在父母身边经历着这一切，而他们却帮不上忙。你甚至无法真正告诉任何人。这让我着迷，不仅仅是他，而是童年的那种普遍问题。
So you decided to murder him?
所以你决定杀了他？
Not that I would murder him, but if I chose to murder him, it would be the perfect murder, because every murder needs a motive, means, and opportunity, isn't that it?
不是说我会去杀了他，但如果我选择杀了他，那将是一次完美的谋杀，因为每次谋杀都需要动机、手段和机会，不是吗？
Yeah.
是的。
But it needs motive. Now, if someone came, Magritte or whoever-- what was the name of that-- Maigret?
但它需要动机。现在，如果有人来了，马格利特（Magritte）或者谁——那个名字叫什么——迈格雷（Maigret）？
Maigret.
迈格雷。
Was that the name of the detective? The French detective? If he came and found Christoph dead at his front door with a big butcher's knife through his heart, he wouldn't have a clue, because I'm back in England or Ireland. I just got on the plane, I went straight to his house. I rang his doorbell. He opened the door. There's a few flaws, I realize in this, but anyway.
那是那个侦探的名字吗？那个法国侦探？如果他过来发现克里斯托弗死在他的前门，胸口插着一把大屠刀，他会毫无头绪，因为我当时回到了英国或爱尔兰。我就直接坐上飞机，直接去了他家。我按了他的门铃。他开了门。我意识到这其中有一些漏洞，但不管怎样。
Like if someone else opened the door?
比如如果别人开了门呢？
Exactly. And how do I recognize him, and all that sort of thing. But he opens the door--
正是如此。我该怎么认出他，还有诸如此类的事情。但他开了门——
You mean now that he's grown up?
你是说现在他长大了？
Exactly. It doesn't really stand up. But anyway, I stab him in the heart. He dies. I get back in the taxi, which I've asked to wait a few doors away. I go to the airport. I go back home. And then Maigret comes around, and where's the motive? There's absolutely no motive. He's just found someone killed in the middle of the afternoon, and everyone loved him, because he's probably turned into a nice person.
没错。这逻辑真的站不住脚。但无论如何，我刺入他的心脏。他死了。我回到已经在几个门外等候的出租车里。我去机场。我回家了。然后迈格雷来调查，动机在哪儿？根本没有任何动机。他只是发现有人在下午被杀了，而每个人都爱他，因为他可能已经变成了一个好人。
And because he beat you up 25 years ago?
仅仅因为他25年前打过你？
Well, yeah. I have to say that this fantasy was particularly strong before I got successful. As soon as Father Ted took off, I kind of dropped it. The worst thing about it, though, is that he'll never know that all these things happened.
嗯，是的。我必须说，在我成功之前，这种幻想特别强烈。一旦《弗雷德神父》火了，我就放弃了这个念头。不过最糟糕的是，他永远不会知道这一切发生过。
He'll never know you wrote Father Ted.
他永远不会知道你写了《弗雷德神父》。
Yeah. Maybe instead of killing him, I should just learn how to say, I wrote Father Ted. Get on a plane, go over, ring the doorbell, he comes to the door, [SPEAKING FRENCH]. Run away.
是的。也许我不该杀了他，而应该学学怎么说“我写了《弗雷德神父》”。坐上飞机，过去，按响门铃，他过来开门，然后（用法文）说：“我写了《弗雷德神父》。”然后跑掉。
To be honest with you, in the end, it's a mug's game, isn't it? It's like answering critics, which I've done once or twice, very stupidly. You can't, as I think Oscar Wilde said, roll around in the mud with them. And you can't roll around in the mud with your bullies. You can't let them know that you still have these things. But it was a real problem for me. My sense of injustice was so keen that I just couldn't sleep sometimes.
老实说，到最后，这不过是一场愚蠢的游戏，不是吗？就像回应批评者一样，我也曾非常愚蠢地做过一两次。我想奥斯卡·王尔德说过，你不能和他们一起在泥潭里打滚。你也不能和你的霸凌者在泥潭里打滚。你不能让他们知道你还介意这些事。但这对我来说真的是个问题。我的正义感如此敏锐，以至于有时我都睡不着觉。
But you know I've been invited to the school reunion, and they'll be there, the boys who threw me into Roath Park Lake.
但你知道我受邀参加学校同学会了，他们也会在那儿，那些把我扔进罗斯公园湖的男孩们。
I'd bring a knife.
我会带把刀。
I've got a better idea than that. They've asked me to donate something for the raffle. So I'm going to put together a package called My Fantastic Life. And in the package will be my two best selling books, a note saying, "Dear Jon, sorry I missed you, hopefully we'll meet up soon, best, Nick Hornby," and a photograph of me with my arm around Zoe Ball. What do you think?
我有比那更好的主意。他们让我为抽奖活动捐赠些东西。所以我准备了一个名为“我的精彩人生”的包裹。包裹里会有我那两本畅销书，一张写着“亲爱的乔恩，抱歉没能见到你，希望我们很快能见面，最好的祝福，尼克·洪比（Nick Hornby）”的便条，以及一张我和佐伊·鲍尔（Zoe Ball）搂着手臂的照片。你觉得怎么样？
Well, the Nick Hornby thing isn't great.
嗯，尼克·洪比那个东西不太行。
That's the best I've got, I'm afraid. I can do no better.
恐怕这就是我能拿出的最好的东西了。我做不到更好了。
My six-year-old son says to me, were you thrown in a lake? Yes, I say, I was thrown in a lake when I was 16. Why, he asks. Because I was fat, I say. And there's two lessons to be learned from this. Don't be a bully and don't be fat. Will you show me what it looks like, he asks. Me being fat or me being thrown in a lake? Both, he says. I puff up my cheeks, waddle comically around, fall over and say splash. Will you do it again in slow motion, he says. So I do. This time I add some dialogue. Please don't throw me in the lake. No. Splash. Will you sound more scared, says Joel, and put a cushion under your shirt? And so I do. Please, I shout, waddling grotesquely, I might drown. Please no, no. You were so fat, says my son.
我六岁的儿子问我：你被扔进湖里了吗？我说，是的，我在16岁时被扔进湖里过。为什么，他问。我说，因为我当时很胖。这件事有两个教训。不要欺负别人，也不要长得太胖。他问，你能演示一下那是什么样子的吗？是演示我变胖的样子，还是被扔进湖里的样子？他说，两个都要。我鼓起腮帮子，滑稽地扭动着走来走去，摔倒在地，发出“噗通”一声。他说，能慢动作再来一遍吗？所以我照做了。这次我加入了一些对话。我大喊：“请不要把我扔进湖里。不。噗通。”Joel说，你能表现得更害怕一点，然后往衬衫里塞个垫子吗？我也照做了。我怪异地扭动着走过去，大喊：“求求你，我会淹死的。求求你，不要，不。”我儿子说，你当时真的好胖。
I spend two hours putting together the package for the raffle, My Fantastic Life, but I couldn't decide what to include. Should I add a copy of my bank statement, or would that be taking it too far? So I dump the idea, and instead I brought along Simon, my producer.
我花了两个小时整理那个抽奖包裹，“我的精彩人生”，但我无法决定该放些什么进去。我是该放一份我的银行账单副本，还是那样做太过分了？所以我放弃了这个念头，反而带上了我的制片人西蒙（Simon）。
This is the spot where it happened. This is exactly where. We were walking down here. Nobody said anything. They just all at once picked me up and threw me in, which leads me to suspect that it was preplanned. And then we all went back to one of their houses and watched Top of The Pops. Should we go? It's just up there.
这就是事情发生的地点。就在这儿。我们当时正沿着这里走。没人说什么。他们就突然一起把我抱起来扔了进去，这让我怀疑这是预谋好的。然后我们都回到了他们其中一人的家里看了《流行音乐之巅》（Top of The Pops）。我们走吧？就在上面。
I'm just wondering why six people that you could go and sit in a room and watch Top of The Pops with afterwards would want to conspire to throw you in the lake?
我只是在想，为什么六个你可以坐在一起看《流行音乐之巅》的人，会密谋把你扔进湖里？
What are you saying?
你在说什么？
I'm not saying anything. I'm just asking why you think that they decided to throw you in the lake?
我没说什么。我只是在问，为什么你认为他们决定把你扔进湖里？
I don't like the tone of your question.
我不喜欢你提问的语气。
Shall I rephrase it a different way?
我换种说法好吗？
Yeah, rephrase it.
好的，换一种。
Why do you think that they threw you in the lake? What had happened? What went wrong?
你认为他们为什么把你扔进湖里？发生了什么？哪里出了错？
You're not rephrasing it, you're just putting a different tone on. You're putting some [? claring ?] tone onto it. It's still the same bloody question. I have no idea what you're talking about. No, there was no reason at all. That's my answer.
你没有换说法，你只是换了个语调。你加了一种……刻薄的语调。这还是同一个该死的问题。我不知道你在说什么。不，根本没有任何原因。这就是我的答案。
So six of your friends from school, for no reason at all, decided to throw you in the lake?
所以你学校里的六个朋友，没有任何理由，决定把你扔进湖里？
Are you trying to rile me?
你是在试图激怒我吗？
I'm not trying to rile you. I'm just trying to find out what happened.
我不是在试图激怒你。我只是在试图搞清楚发生了什么。
I told you, they picked me up and threw me in the lake.
我告诉过你了，他们把我抱起来扔进了湖里。
That's the action. What's the reasoning behind it?
那是动作。背后的原因是什么？
I don't know. I'm the one who was thrown in the lake. I wasn't the one who planned it.
我不知道。我是那个被扔进湖里的人。我又不是那个策划它的人。
So basically you're saying it's an inexplicable act, and it happened for no real reason at all.
所以你基本上是在说，这是一种无法解释的行为，发生时根本没有任何真正的理由。
But it might be because I was fat.
但也有可能是因为我当时很胖。
Later I tell Simon that I can't help thinking that, had he been there, he would have thrown me in the lake. And Simon says, if I think that about him, then I don't know him very well.
后来我告诉西蒙，我忍不住在想，如果他在场，他也会把我扔进湖里。西蒙说，如果我那样想他，那我就根本不了解他。
It was with trepidation that I approached the back room of the Discovery Pub on Lakeside Drive for the reunion of the Cardiff High School Class of 1985. I had a mental picture of a room full of thugs just jumping on me the minute I walked in, but instead I bumped into Sarah Thomas, who'd been, without any doubt, Cardiff High's most attractive enigma from the age of 14 upwards.
我怀着忐忑的心情走进了Discovery酒吧的后厅，去参加卡迪夫高中1985届的同学会。我的脑海里是一幅满屋子恶霸在我进门那一刻就冲向我的画面，但相反，我遇到了萨拉·托马斯（Sarah Thomas），毫无疑问，她从14岁起就是卡迪夫高中最迷人的谜团。
How are you?
你好吗？
Very well.
非常好。
20 years.
20年了。
I'm very well, Ronson.
我很好，罗森。
Nervous?
紧张吗？
Stressed. I'm a lawyer. I shouldn't be stressed, but I am.
压力很大。我是个律师。我不该感到压力的，但我确实有。
Does it feel like the last 20 years of your life just haven't happened?
感觉过去20年的生活好像没发生过一样吗？
They have. I've got wrinkles to show.
发生了。我有皱纹为证。
No, you haven't.
不，你没有。
You look better.
你看起来更好了。
Yeah, I've aged well. Why were you nervous?
是的，我保养得不错。你为什么紧张？
The people I was going to see. And I hoped I was going to see you. That was a big thing. So you see, it wasn't all bad, because I really wanted to see you again.
因为我要见到的人。而且我希望我能见到你。那是一件大事。所以你看，并不全是坏事，因为我真的很想再见到你。
Jon. John Audrey.
乔恩。约翰·奥德里（John Audrey）。
Jonathan Audrey.
乔纳森·奥德里。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Hey, Sarah.
（听不清）。嘿，萨拉。
How are you, sweetie?
你好吗，亲爱的？
That was Jonathan Audrey. I remember nothing about him except for his name.
那是乔纳森·奥德里。除了名字外，我对他毫无记忆。
Yeah. He hasn't changed.
是的。他一点也没变。
No, he hasn't. Still cheeky.
没变，还是那么厚脸皮。
Something unexpected happens at the reunion. I have a lovely time. What I don't remember, it turns out, are the good times. Really, I keep saying, we did that? It's bizarre you don't remember that, people keep replying. It's as if I've scrubbed from my memory anything that contradicts my image of school as the worst days of my life.
同学会上发生了一些意想不到的事。我度过了一段美好的时光。结果发现，我不记得的竟然是那些快乐的时光。我一直在说，我们真的做过那个吗？人们不停地回答，你不记得那个真是太奇怪了。就好像我从记忆中抹去了任何与我“学校是我人生中最黑暗时期”这一形象相悖的东西。
Do you think I've given myself false memories?
你认为我给自己植入了虚假记忆吗？
Yeah, I think you--
是的，我认为你——
You think things weren't as bad?
你认为当时的情况没有那么糟？
They weren't as bad. You've never talked about my house, and I think you had a nice time at my house.
没那么糟。你从来没提过我家，但我认为你在我家过得很愉快。
Yeah, I did. Very much so.
是的，确实如此。非常愉快。
And then Dai Lewis, the man I thought had thrown me in the lake, comes over. He says I've got it all wrong, very wrong.
然后戴·刘易斯（Dai Lewis），那个我以为把我扔进湖里的男人，走了过来。他说我完全搞错了，大错特错。
Do you remember it as a good time?
你还记得那段时光很美好吗？
I remember it as a very good time, school.
我记得那是一段非常美好的时光，上学的时候。
What do you remember of the day of the lake incident?
关于湖边事故那天，你记得什么？
Just good time.
就是一段美好的时光。
That we all went down to the lake, and what? We all jumped in together?
我们都去了湖边，然后呢？我们一起跳了进去？
Yeah.
是的。
That's how you remember it?
你是这样记得的？
Do you?
你呢？
No, I remember being picked up and thrown. Is that really how you remember it?
不，我记得我是被抱起来扔进去的。你是真的那样记得吗？
Do you remember anyone else going in the lake?
你记得还有别人掉进湖里吗？
No.
不。
Just you?
就只有你？
Yes.
是的。
Wrong.
错了。
Did we all go in the lake?
我们都跳进湖里了吗？
Everyone.
每个人都跳了。
Everyone? Like who?
每个人？比如谁？
Garret, Dick.
加勒特（Garret），迪克（Dick）。
Paul Morris.
保罗·莫里斯（Paul Morris）。
Yeah.
是的。
What, we all jumped in, in a kind of joyous, youthful frenzy?
什么，我们都跳了进去，是在一种欢快、青春的狂热中？
I would say so.
我想是的。
What do you remember of being in the lake?
你还记得在湖里时的情景吗？
It was really disgusting. But it washed off.
真的很恶心。但洗掉就好了。
Was there any pushing going on at all? Did we all jump in of our own free will?
当时有任何推搡发生吗？我们都是自愿跳进去的吗？
I don't think there was any pushing. Do you really think there was pushing? Jon, really, honestly?
我不认为有任何推搡。你真的认为有推搡吗？乔恩，真的，老实说？
The way I remember it is that we were all walking along, and then--
我的记忆是，我们都在沿着湖走，然后——
Because obviously, this is a really big thing in your life.
因为很显然，这对你的人生来说是一件非常大的事。
No, it's not.
不，并不是。
No, it is. It obviously is. Go on, tell me.
不，它是。这显然就是。继续，告诉我。
And then some look passed between you, and you picked me up and just threw me in.
然后你们之间递了一个眼色，你们就把我抱起来，直接扔了进去。
How could I have picked you up? You were massive. There's no way. Jon, come on. You could've picked me up. Pregnant silence.
我怎么可能抱得起你？你当时太庞大了。根本不可能。乔恩，得了吧。你能抱得起我才对。（令人窒息的沉默）
When you remember our time together, what do you remember?
当你回忆我们在一起的时光时，你记得什么？
I remember it as being really good. I remember you, John Morris, Garrett, Dick as a really good time. No other thoughts.
我记得那非常美好。我记得你、约翰·莫里斯、加勒特、迪克在一起度过的非常美好的时光。没别的了。
Do you look back on it as being the happiest days of your life, which is what people say about their school days?
你会回头把它看作你一生中最快乐的时光吗，就是人们通常评价学生时代那样？
No, I do. Don't you?
不，我会。你不吗？
Really the happiest days of your life?
真的，是一生中最快乐的时光？
Apart from my kids being born? Yes. You?
除了我孩子出生的时候？是的。你呢？
No, for me it was like the saddest days of my life.
不，对我来说那是我一生中最悲伤的时光。
Oh, that's really bad. That's really bad.
哦，那真的很糟糕。那真的很糟糕。
Well, I've had very happy days since then.
好吧，从那以后我确实经历过非常快乐的日子。
You were one of the group. There was never any bullying. If you say differently, I think you're fantasizing. You really are.
你是我们中的一员。从来没有任何霸凌。如果你非要说有，我认为你在幻想。你真的是在幻想。
Fantasizing?
幻想？
Absolutely.
绝对是的。
I'm beginning to wonder whether I should be trusting my memory. Do I get a hug, Dai?
我开始怀疑我是否该相信我的记忆了。我能得到一个拥抱吗，戴？
Yeah. Don't stress about it. There was nothing. I was in the lake, too.
可以。别为此感到压力。什么事都没发生。我也跳进湖里了。
And so I go back inside to the disco, amazed at the fragility of memory, and startled that I've spent so long being angry about something that probably never happened. And Simon, my producer, stays outside.
于是我回到迪厅，惊叹于记忆的脆弱，也惊诧于自己竟然花了这么长时间，去愤怒一件可能从未发生过的事情。而我的制片人西蒙则留在外面。
All right, well, Jon's not here now, so I can tell you the truth. I remember the evening vividly. I threw him in the lake-- I was 15-- because he was being an ass. And then somebody else threw his scarf in afterwards, and he had to climb back in and get it. The humiliation of that, I'm not entirely surprised he's still having sleepless nights.
好吧，乔恩现在不在，所以我也能告诉你真相。我清楚地记得那个晚上。我把他扔进了湖里——当时我15岁——因为他当时表现得像个混蛋。然后有人在他之后把他的围巾也扔了进去，他不得不爬回去捡。那种羞辱感，我不奇怪他至今还会夜不能寐。
But why did you do it?
但你为什么要这么做？
Because I was 15 and because he was an ass. That's all the reason I can remember. In a very similar, though more sort of pubescent way, that he is still an ass.
因为我当时15岁，因为他表现得像个混蛋。这就是我能想起的所有原因。用一种非常类似，尽管更青春期一点的方式来说，他现在依然是个混蛋。
What do you think Dai is saying that you all went in the lake? Is he falsely remembering it, do you think? Because you seem to remember it very clearly.
你认为戴说你们都跳进湖里是什么意思？你认为他是记错了吗？因为你似乎记得非常清楚。
I do remember that Dai was there, but I think Dai's memories have been clouded over the years. Why it seems to have festered over the past 20-something years for Jon, I have no idea, but it obviously has. You want the truth on this? I think he was somebody who desperately wanted to be popular. And because of that desperation, he wasn't.
我确实记得戴当时在场，但我认为戴的记忆随着时间的推移变得模糊了。为什么这件事在过去的20多年里一直在乔恩心中发酵，我不知道，但显然它确实发生了。你想听真相吗？我认为他是一个非常渴望受欢迎的人。正因为这种渴望，他才不受欢迎。
That was Paul. And I'd just like to point out, I make more money than him.
那是保罗。我想指出，我赚得比他多。
Jon Ronson, he's the author of the book The Men Who Stare At Goats and other books. A version of this story originally appeared on a radio show that he's been hosting lately for BBC Radio 4, called Jon Ronson On.
乔恩·罗森，他是《凝视山羊的男人们》（The Men Who Stare At Goats）和其他书籍的作者。这个故事的一个版本最初出现在他最近为BBC第四台主持的电台节目《乔恩·罗森谈……》（Jon Ronson On）中。
[MUSIC - "DON'T LET THE SUN GO DOWN ON YOUR GRIEVANCE" BY DANIEL JOHNSTON]
（音乐 - 丹尼尔·约翰斯顿的《不要让太阳落在你的委屈上》）
Act Two, Life Without Leanne. Our program today is about things that never seem to end. And I think there are certain feelings that, at some point or another, all of us have felt and been unable to shake. These feelings stick around for months, they stick around for years, and there are some people in this situation who find it useful to talk about it.
第二幕，《没有莉安的生活》。我们今天的节目是关于那些似乎永远不会结束的事情。我认为有某些感受，在某个时候，我们所有人都曾体会过并且无法摆脱。这些感觉困扰我们几个月，几年，而有些处于这种境况下的人发现讨论它很有用。
Good evening, and welcome to Life Without Leanne. I'm Larry, and this is day 683. That's nearly 98 weeks since Leanne and I broke up.
晚上好，欢迎收听《没有莉安的生活》。我是拉里，今天是第683天。那是莉安和我分手近98周了。
We're going to start out, as always, with our Leanne Watcher of the week. My kudos go out to Mike of Evanston, Illinois, who called in with this eloquent report on a brief encounter he had with Leanne on April 28th.
我们将像往常一样，以“本周莉安观察员”开始。我要向伊利诺伊州埃文斯顿的迈克致敬，他打来电话，讲述了他在4月28日与莉安的一次短暂偶遇，内容非常感人。
Hey Larry, I love the show. Listen, I ran into Leanne last week. She lost some weight, but she's still beautiful, you know. She said she's been exercising, taking classes, doing this, doing that. But it appeared to me that she was struggling to fill some void. Your name didn't come up. But it wasn't so much what she said as what she didn't say.
嘿拉里，我喜欢这个节目。听着，我上周遇到了莉安。她瘦了一些，但她依然很美，你知道的。她说她一直在锻炼、上课、做这做那。但在我看来，她在努力填补某种空虚。没提到你的名字。但重点不是她说了什么，而是她没说什么。
Thanks, Mike. I think we all know what she was trying to say. I wish it all could be such good news, but unfortunately, Operation: Terrible Mistake has not been the success that we anticipated. And I'm afraid we may have to rethink our strategy. As you may recall from our April 20th program, the objectives of Operation: Terrible Mistake were to, one, apply societal pressure; two, foster emotional uncertainty; three, precipitate reevaluation; and ideally, four, achieve reconciliation.
谢谢，迈克。我想我们都知道她想表达什么。我希望一切都能是好消息，但不幸的是，“可怕的错误行动”（Operation: Terrible Mistake）并不像我们预期的那样成功。恐怕我们得重新考虑策略。正如你可能从我们4月20日的节目中所记得的，行动的目标是：第一，施加社会压力；第二，制造情感不确定性；第三，促使重新评估；理想情况下，第四，实现和解。
When I brought up this plan, I suggested the following conversation starter when you would run into Leanne on the street or something. I suggested that you say something like, Leanne, I was so sorry to hear about you and Larry. You make such a wonderful couple, so I don't mind telling you, I think you are making a terrible mistake. This is my own personal opinion on the matter.
当我提出这个计划时，我建议你们在街上偶遇莉安时可以使用这样的开场白。我建议说类似这样的话：“莉安，听说你和拉里的事，我很难过。你们是如此般配的一对，所以我忍不住想说，我认为你犯了一个可怕的错误。这是我个人的看法。”
Now, unfortunately, a number of well-meaning individuals took this suggestion rather more literally than I intended, and repeated it verbatim to Leanne. And some of it sounds like you were practicing it, and it created an effect other than the one I desired. I've now received word through an intermediary that Leanne requests that I quote, "Call off the zombies", unquote. We will honor her wishes as always, but I must emphasize I cannot be held responsible for the behavior of individuals acting on their own initiative.
不幸的是，一些心地善良的人把这个建议看得太字面化了，并一字不差地重复给了莉安。而且听起来像是你们事先排练过，结果造成了与我预期完全相反的效果。我通过中间人收到消息，莉安要求我引用，“叫停那些僵尸”。我们将一如既往地尊重她的意愿，但我必须强调，对于个人自发行为所造成的后果，我概不负责。
I've got the minutes of the most recent Leanne Anonymous meeting, which I'll read to you now. It was our first meeting at Gatsby's. The bartender, Mark, gracefully accommodated us by closing off the back room and supplying extra folding chairs. The meeting started out, we ordered a first round, and it proceeded immediately to old business: the continuing debate on Leanne's eyes, and whether they are turbulent sea green, or sand-flecked moon blue. They are, by the way, sand-flecked moon blue. And conversation turned naturally to the rest of Leanne, her quirky, perky nose, her funny, sunny smile, the perfect curve of her neck, her soft shoulders, and so on, until petty jealousies precluded further discussion.
我拿到了最近一次“莉安匿名会”的会议记录，现在读给你听。这是我们在Gatsby's举行的第一次会议。酒保马克非常体贴地为我们腾出了后厅，并提供了额外的折叠椅。会议开始后，我们点了第一轮酒，随即转入旧议题：关于莉安眼睛的持续争论，它们到底是汹涌的海绿色，还是带有沙斑的月光蓝。顺便说一句，是带有沙斑的月光蓝。谈话自然地转向了莉安的其他部分，她那古灵精怪的鼻子、灿烂阳光的笑容、颈部的完美曲线、柔软的肩膀等等，直到小嫉妒阻碍了进一步讨论。
Soon thereafter, we took a break to order some refreshments, and then it was time to welcome new members. This stubby and not particularly attractive man, who had been spotted with Leanne as recently as mid-January, stood up, and he said, my name is Harry, and I love Leanne. Harry then related his long, sad tale, the details of which we are all too familiar with. He ended with that same old refrain, she met this guy, she says she's deliriously happy.
此后不久，我们休息了一下点些点心，然后是欢迎新成员的时间。这个身材敦实、长相并不出众的男人，他在1月中旬还被人看到和莉安在一起，他站起来说：“我叫哈里，我爱莉安。”哈里接着讲述了他那个漫长、悲伤的故事，细节大家都已烂熟于心。他以那句老调重弹结束：“她遇到了那个家伙，她说她欣喜若狂。”
That prompted Gunther, who really doesn't speak very often, to speak up. She's deliriously happy, eh? he said, staring into his beer, that guy is doomed. Those of us who could still laugh about it did, and we voted to adjourn.
那引发了冈瑟（Gunther），他很少开口，但他说道：“欣喜若狂，是吗？”他盯着啤酒杯，“那个家伙死定了。”那些还能笑得出来的人都笑了，我们投票决定休会。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
（音乐响起）
We all know what that music means. It's time for this week's Leanne Challenge. Leanne is what she eats, but how well do you know what she eats? Everybody knows Leanne likes horseradish on her hamburgers, but what kind of horseradish? OK, here's a hint. She received a case of it last Christmas. The answer to last week's challenge was, you guessed it, from left to right. Now, I know a lot of people thought there was a trick to that question, but there wasn't.
我们都知道那音乐意味着什么。是时候进行本周的“莉安挑战”了。莉安人如其食，但你有多了解她吃什么？大家都知道莉安喜欢在汉堡上加辣根，但是什么样的辣根？好，给个提示。她去年圣诞节收到了一箱。上周挑战的答案是——你猜对了——从左到右。我知道很多人认为那个问题有陷阱，但并没有。
[MUSIC - "PLEASE MR. POSTMAN" BY THE MARVELETTES]
（音乐 - The Marvelettes的《请，邮差先生》）
It's time for the mail. The mail ran heavy this week with entries to the candid Leanne photo contest. I think I need to remind everybody that the rules clearly state that Leanne must be the only person shown in the photograph. In case any of you want to resubmit, I'm going to extend the deadline for two weeks until May 23rd. Please remember entries can't be returned.
是时候处理邮件了。这周的邮件很多，都是参加“莉安生活照竞赛”的投稿。我想提醒大家，规则明确规定照片中只能有莉安一人。如果你们中有人想重新提交，我将把截止日期延长两周，至5月23日。请记住，参赛作品恕不退还。
First letter, one of our far flung correspondents, Reggie of Buffalo Grove, Illinois, who writes in, and I think this is very interesting. We've gotten a number of letters like this. He writes, "Larry, isn't it time you got on with your life? It's been nearly two years since Leanne broke up with you--" actually, we're a couple weeks short of that, but anyway, he says "it's been actually two years since Leanne broke up with you, and I hate to tell you, pal, but it's over. O-V-E-R. But listen," he says, "there are a lot of other chicks in the sea, my friend, and they are yours for the picking. Go for it."
第一封信，来自我们远方的通讯员，伊利诺伊州布法罗格罗夫的雷吉，他写道，我认为这非常有趣。我们收到过很多这样的信。他写道：“拉里，你是不是该继续你的生活了？莉安和你分手快两年了——”实际上，离那还有几周，但无论如何，他说：“事实上莉安和你分手已经两年了，我不愿打击你，伙计，但结束了。完——了。但是听着，”他说，“天涯何处无芳草，朋友。去追求她们吧。”
Well, Reggie, I don't know quite how to answer that. It's difficult to determine exactly what it is you're driving at. I mean, I'm afraid I don't share your bitter perspective, and I don't really get all of your playground aphorisms, but please understand when I suggest this: you know nothing about love. But thanks for the letter, Reg. Your Larry Loves Leanne t-shirt is in the mail. That's it for Life Without Leanne this week, and let's hope it's the last week. I'm Larry, and I love Leanne.
好吧，雷吉，我不知道该怎么回答。很难确定你到底想说什么。我的意思是，恐怕我无法认同你那刻薄的观点，我也不太理解你所有的操场格言，但请理解我对此的看法：你对爱情一无所知。但谢谢你的来信，雷吉。“拉里爱莉安”T恤已经在邮寄的路上了。本周的《没有莉安的生活》就是这样，希望这是最后一周。我是拉里，我爱莉安。
Larry Doyle wishes it known that he now loves Becky. They have three kids together.
拉里·多伊尔希望大家知道他现在爱着贝基（Becky）。他们有三个孩子。
[MUSIC - "IT'S ALWAYS YOU" BY CHET BAKER]
（音乐 - 切特·贝克（Chet Baker）的《永远是你》）
Coming up, an inhuman situation made human through sheer force of politeness. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，一个非人的处境通过纯粹的礼貌变得人性化。稍后回来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, It's Never Over, stories of feelings and situations that will not end, no matter what it is that we want. Act Three, Deal of a Lifetime.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。当然，我们每周节目都会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种相关故事。今天节目主题是“永不结束”，讲述那些无论我们想要什么都不会结束的情感和处境。第三幕，《终身契约》。
The beauty of most business transactions is that they are cut and dried. No emotion, you do this, I do that. Here's the money, goodbye. Especially goodbye. They are easy that way. Sarah Koenig tells this story of a business transaction that everyone involved thought was going to be quick and simple, that has turned out to actually be kind of never-ending. It was a real estate deal in Sag Harbor, New York. Sag Harbor is one of those places that used to be a fishing village, but now it's an artsy, tourist town in the Hamptons, super expensive. Here's Sarah.
大多数商业交易的美妙之处在于它们干脆利落。没有感情，你做这个，我做那个。钱给你，再见。尤其是“再见”。它们就是这么简单。萨拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）讲述了这个所有参与者都认为会简单快捷，结果却变得永无止境的商业交易故事。那是纽约州萨格港（Sag Harbor）的一笔房地产交易。萨格港曾经是个渔村，现在是汉普顿的一个艺术气息浓厚的旅游小镇，贵得离谱。听听萨拉的报道。
My stepsister, Rue, wanted a house in Sag Harbor, New York, badly, and she couldn't really afford it. Then one day, she found out about a lovely house on Main Street listed for two prices. The more expensive listing included a house, a shed, and a little garden. The cheaper listing included a house, a shed, a little garden, and Ned.
我的继姐妹露（Rue）非常渴望在纽约州萨格港拥有一套房子，但她实在买不起。然后有一天，她得知主街（Main Street）上有一套可爱的房子，列出了两个价格。较贵的价格包括房子、仓库和小花园。较便宜的价格包括房子、仓库、小花园，还有奈德（Ned）。
Well, the way I identify Ned is my man. People laugh at this, but he really is mine. He's the man that came with the house.
嗯，我对奈德的定义是——我的男人。人们听到这儿会笑，但他真的是我的。他是随房子附送的男人。
The deal was this: Rue moved into her dream house at $110,000 discount. The catch was Ned, an elderly, sick man, who sold the house cheap on one condition, that he never have to move out. Rue lives in the upstairs apartment. Ned lives in the more spacious downstairs, where he will stay until he dies. While Ned is working in his little downtown shop which sells classical music CDs, Rue gives us a tour.
交易是这样的：露以11万美金的折扣搬进了她的梦想之屋。条件就是奈德，一位上了年纪、身体状况不佳的老人，他以低价卖掉房子，但有一个前提：他永远不必搬走。露住在楼上的公寓，奈德住在空间更宽敞的楼下，他会一直住到去世。当奈德在市中心的小店卖古典音乐CD时，露带我们参观了这房子。
We're coming into Ned's portion of the house, which is where he's lived for, I think, maybe 20 years, I'm not sure. Which is good for him too, because he's older, it's all on street level, he doesn't have to climb any stairs. And also, he's lost a lot of his sight, which is one reason why he really didn't want to leave this house.
我们现在走进奈德住的这部分房子，他大概住在这儿有20年了，我不确定。这对他也很好，因为他年纪大了，这里都在街道水平面上，他不必爬楼梯。而且，他的视力下降了很多，这也是他真的不想搬离这房子的原因之一。
Unlke the mansions across the street, this house isn't big or fancy. It was built perhaps 100 years ago for the workers in the local watch case factory. When she bought it, Rue was 36 and single. The idea that she could inhabit only two rooms of her new house didn't seem problematic. What she did not foresee was that, in the space of a year, she would acquire a puppy, a husband, and a baby. She tries to focus on the deal's advantages. The cramped quarters have taught her to resolve fights with her husband rather than flee them, she says. Still, she can't deny that the population boom in her apartment has made Ned's downstairs look especially attractive.
不同于街对面那些豪宅，这房子既不大也不华丽。它大概建于100年前，是为当地表壳厂的工人盖的。露买这房子时，36岁，单身。她觉得只能住在这新家的两个房间里的想法并不成问题。她没有预见到的是，在一年之内，她会有了一只小狗、一个丈夫和一个婴儿。她试图关注这笔交易的优势。她说狭小的空间教会了她解决与丈夫的争吵，而不是逃避。不过，她无法否认，家里人口激增使得奈德的楼下空间显得格外诱人。
And this is the living room.
这是客厅。
Is this where you would have the bedroom if you were down here? Would you use that as the master bedroom?
如果你住在楼下，你会把卧室设在这里吗？你会把它用作主卧吗？
Well, actually, I think I would change the whole back of the house if I were down here. As you might guess, I've had a few imaginings of what I would like to do with the space down here, but not too many. I don't like to get carried away with myself prematurely. You know, terrible things to think of.
嗯，其实如果我住在这里，我会改变整个房子的后面。如你所料，我对如何利用这里的空间有过一些遐想，但不多。我不想过早地让自己得意忘形。你知道，这想法挺可怕的。
Why are they terrible things to think of?
为什么说这些想法很可怕？
Well, I don't know. There's this vulture-like aspect of it when you start talking about what you'd like to do. I mean, there's no getting around that. How can I talk about what I'd like to do? I'd never get to do it until he's moved on from this world.
嗯，我不知道。当你开始谈论你想做什么时，有一种像秃鹰一样的感觉。我的意思是，这是绕不开的。我怎么能谈论我想做什么呢？在他离开这个世界之前，我永远也做不了。
Well, we are now standing in the second parlor of this house on Main Street in Sag Harbor, and I've lived here since 1985. I sold it to Rue, I think, in '95. And I never expected to be alive this long. Poor Rue.
嗯，我们现在正站在萨格港主街这栋房子的第二个客厅里，我从1985年就住在这里了。我想我在95年把它卖给了露。我从没想过我还能活这么久。可怜的露。
To Ned, who is 78, selling his house from under himself was an ingenious way to stay in a place he considers home. A pianist who made his living as an editor, Ned has spent his life getting money and then spending it all. By the time he put his house on the market, he was sick and broke. He didn't have the will to move. The Main Street house is the only one he's ever owned. It's crammed with antiques and oriental rugs, and reminders of his elegant New Orleans upbringing. A large romantic portrait of him from 1951 hangs in the parlor. In the kitchen is a framed photograph of Stillwood, his grandmother's plantation house.
对78岁的奈德来说，把自己住的房子卖掉是一种让他留在这个他称之为“家”的地方的巧妙方式。奈德曾是一名钢琴家，后来以编辑为生，他的一生都在赚钱，然后又全部花光。当他把房子推向市场时，他病了，而且破产了。他没有搬家的意志。主街上的这栋房子是他唯一拥有的财产。里面堆满了古董、东方地毯，以及他那优雅的新奥尔良成长背景的遗迹。客厅里悬挂着他1951年的一幅浪漫画像。厨房里是一张“静林”（Stillwood）的照片，那是他祖母的种植园大屋。
The little silver coffee set, this set right here, a coffee pot, a cream pitcher, and a sugar pitcher, and a tray, my mother said was from the Civil War down in New Orleans, and had been buried in the garden to keep General Butler, Spoon Butler they called him, to keep it from him. And I said, oh, mother, on the bottom of each piece in here it says 1893. And she said, well, that's a stock number. In reality, my mother was not to be moved by this. And when I took the tray to a silversmith in New York to have it redone, he said, has this tray ever been buried in the ground? Because there are all sorts of minerals in it that you only find in the ground. And I told him the story, he said, well, I bet your mother was right.
那套银色的咖啡具，就是这套，一个咖啡壶、一个奶油罐、一个糖罐和一个托盘，我母亲说是在新奥尔良内战期间留下的，当时被埋在花园里以躲避巴特勒将军（General Butler）——他们称他为“勺子巴特勒”（Spoon Butler），为了不让他抢走。我说：“哦，母亲，每件底座上都写着1893年。”她说：“那是库存编号。”事实上，我的母亲对这些说法无动于衷。当我把托盘带到纽约找银匠重修时，他说：“这托盘埋在土里过吗？因为上面有只有在土里才能找到的矿物质。”我告诉了他那个故事，他说：“嗯，我打赌你母亲是对的。”
Besides the house and its occasional ailments, a leaky skylight, an overflowing garbage can, what unites these two households is the anticipation of Ned's death. Back when they first negotiated the deal, nobody thought he would still be alive today.
除了房子本身和不时出现的小毛病——漏水的天窗、溢出的垃圾桶——将这两户人家联系在一起的，是对于奈德离世的预感。早在他们最初协商这笔交易时，没人想到他今天还会活着。
He had had a heart attack, and he had had a history of heart disease. I don't know how long a history. He had had bypass surgery, and then, right after the closing, two weeks after the closing, he had another heart attack, and I talked to him from the hospital, and he sounded quite authentically sick, I have to say. And that was six years ago.
他患过心脏病，而且有心脏病史。我不知道有多久了。他做过搭桥手术，然后在成交后，成交两周后，他又犯了心脏病，我从医院和他通话，我不得不说，他听起来确实病得很重。那是六年前的事了。
The trouble is I all of the sudden began to get better, and was going around full of energy, and I feel perfectly good most of the time. I mean, I wake up and I embrace the day, so to speak. Well, not the early day.
麻烦的是，我突然开始好转了，到处跑，充满活力，而且大部分时间我感觉良好。我的意思是，我醒来迎接新的一天，可以这么说。嗯，不是清晨。
The contract that binds Ned and Rue has led them to live together separately. They don't consider each other family, or even friends. They don't invite each other over for dinner or drop by each other's apartment for a chat. When they do talk, their conversation is almost exclusively about the house. Like considerate roommates, they try not to offend each other with their habits.
约束奈德和露的合同让他们过上了“住在一起却互不干扰”的生活。他们不认为对方是家人，甚至是朋友。他们不邀请对方吃晚饭，也不去对方的公寓聊天。当他们谈话时，内容几乎完全围绕着房子。像体贴的室友一样，他们尽量不让自己的生活习惯冒犯到对方。
I try to figure out when maybe nobody's upstairs, and that's when I play. But sometimes, I realize they are upstairs, but then I go ahead and play anyhow. I'm sure it must bother them. It would bother me. I've played the piano ever since I was nine years old, and very sad by the fact that I can no longer read music, because I've forgotten all those pieces that I learned all those years ago. But I now can sit down and simply play what comes out. And oddly enough, sometimes what comes out is very, very nice. It's always very sad. Oh, there have been moving evenings here, let me tell you, not a dry handkerchief in the house.
我尽量避开楼上可能没人的时候，然后在那时候演奏。但有时我意识到他们就在楼上，但我还是继续演奏。我相信这肯定会打扰到他们。要是我的话，我也会困扰的。我从9岁起就开始弹钢琴，但很悲哀的一点是我再也看不懂乐谱了，因为我已经忘了多年前学过的那些曲子。但我现在可以坐下来随意演奏流露出的旋律。奇怪的是，有时流露出的旋律非常、非常美妙。总是非常悲伤。哦，这里曾有过令人感动的夜晚，让我告诉你，屋子里没有一条干的手帕。
[PIANO PLAYING]
（钢琴演奏）
In fact, Rue likes his playing. She's never told him so, but she finds it soothing when the music drifts into her bedroom when she and the baby are taking a nap. And he has never told her that he finds her presence upstairs comforting. Still, there are complicated feelings on both sides.
事实上，露很喜欢他的演奏。她从没告诉过他，但当她和孩子午睡时，音乐飘进卧室，让她感到安宁。而他也从没告诉过她，他觉得她在楼上会让他感到安慰。尽管如此，双方都有着复杂的情感。
I do like Ned. And I do feel kind of benevolent towards him, like I'm taking care of him sometimes. He just inspires that in people. But then, I'm not going to be terribly, terribly sorry when he dies. I'm going to be sorry, but I'm also going to feel some relief. It's very strange.
我确实喜欢奈德。我对他有一种仁慈感，感觉我有时是在照顾他。他就是会激发人们这种感情。但之后，我不会在奈德去世时感到太难过。我会感到难过，但我也会感到某种解脱。这非常奇怪。
Every time I ask him how you are doing, or take care, I always get this little twinge, because it's-- there's a twinge. A twinge of like, how are things going, or how are you doing, and it's just this wicked twinge comes over me, because I think that I'd a little bit like to hear, not so great.
每次我问他“你怎么样”或者“保重”，我总是会感到一阵刺痛，因为它……有一种刺痛。像“进展如何”或者“你还好吗”这种刺痛，一股邪恶的刺痛涌上心头，因为我想听到的是“不太好”。
Do you think he's keyed in to this other conversation in your head?
你认为他察觉到你心里的这个对话了吗？
Well, as I said, Ned's no fool.
嗯，如我所说，奈德可不是傻瓜。
I'm aware that the other side can't be all that thrilled that I'm still there. But she's been very nice to me. And I think I've been very nice to her, I think.
我知道对方对我的存在并不感到那么兴奋。但她一直对我很好。我想我也一直对她很好。
She obviously likes you.
她显然喜欢你。
Well, I hope so, because I like her.
嗯，我希望如此，因为我也喜欢她。
But she's also waiting for your demise.
但她也在等待你的终结。
Oh, I'm sure.
哦，我肯定。
Does it make you feel guilty that you got better?
你康复了会让你感到内疚吗？
I don't think I feel guilty. Maybe I do. I'm just sorry that there is Rue sitting up there. She can't help but wait, biting her fingernails, probably. It sounds heartless put this way, and I guess it is. When one begins picking it apart this way, it sounds really quite awful, as though I'm just squelching the life of a young couple, and now a brand-new life.
我不认为我感到内疚。也许有吧。我只是为楼上的露感到遗憾。她忍不住在等待，咬着指甲。这样说起来显得很冷酷，我想确实如此。当人们开始这样解剖它时，听起来真的很糟糕，就好像我压制了一个年轻家庭的生活，现在又加上了一个全新的生命。
A lot of people would say that Rue looks like the heartless one in this arrangement, that there she is, waiting for a gentleman to die.
很多人会说露在这个安排里看起来像是个冷酷的人，她坐在那儿等待一位绅士去世。
That's why I think this kind of speculation is-- there's a certain falseness about it. That, yes, these thoughts flicker across every mind, mine as well as hers, I'm sure. But we're civilized beings, and I did what I thought I had to do, and I also think that she did what she felt she, maybe not had to do, but she did what she wanted to do.
这就是为什么我认为这种猜测是——有一种虚假性。是的，这些想法会在每个人的脑海中闪过，我的，还有她的，我相信。但我们是文明人，我做了我认为必须要做的事，我也认为她做了她觉得……也许不是“必须”要做的事，但她做了她想做的事。
It's been very civilized, I think. Rue and I are polite to each other. We don't let our feelings carry us into territory that is uncharted, and really will always be uncharted.
我认为这非常文明。露和我对彼此都很客气。我们不让我们的情感带我们进入未经探索、且永远无法探索的领地。
What territory is that?
那是什么领地？
The territory that she resents the fact that I'm still alive, and I resent the fact that she wants me to die. Better to be on the surface than not, because it's unanswerable. And it's territory that I'm unable to explore. And I don't think Rue is able to explore it to any benefit either. It's supposed to be that total honesty is examining every scrap of the brain, our emotions and whatnot, is supposed to advance something, but it usually depresses rather than advances, I think.
那是她对“我依然活着”这件事感到愤恨，而我对“她想让我死”这件事感到愤恨的领地。最好维持在表面，因为这是无解的。这是我无法探索的领地。我也认为露探索它并不会有任何益处。所谓全面坦诚，就是审视大脑、情感等等每一个碎片，本应推动某种进步，但我认为它通常只会让人沮丧，而不是进步。
Because of his upbringing, Ned comes to this position naturally. But it's remarkable to me that my stepsister, a '70s wild child still known to say things like virtue is a load of crap, has come to understand the power of polite restraint. In private, of course, away from Ned, she's unapologetic about what lurks beneath their relationship.
由于他的教养，奈德自然地站在这个位置上。但令我惊奇的是，我的继姐妹，一个70年代的野孩子，还经常说“美德就是狗屎”之类的话，却学会了克制礼貌的力量。当然，在私底下，远离奈德的时候，她对自己关系下潜藏的东西并不避讳。
I don't feel so very guilty of that, because I don't feel anything that anybody else wouldn't feel. I know how people are. I'm not worse than anybody. There's no person-- Mother Teresa could be living in this apartment if she were young, with a baby and a husband, and not have those thoughts. OK, I know that. It seems to me that people waste an awful lot of time having pretenses about what they're supposed to feel, when what they really feel is what they really feel. Why not just-- you can't tell life to be something that it's not going to be, that it isn't. You can't argue with it. I don't mind being just a human being. That's fine.
我并不对此感到那么内疚，因为我感觉到的都是任何人都会有的感觉。我知道人们是怎么样的。我并不比任何人更坏。没有谁——特蕾莎修女如果住在这个公寓里，如果她年轻，带着孩子和丈夫，也不会没有这些想法。好吧，我知道。在我看来，人们在装模作样表达自己“应该”有什么感觉上浪费了太多时间，而真实的感受就是真实的感受。为什么要……你不能要求生活成为它不会成为的样子，它不是。你不能和它争论。我不介意做一个普通人。那就很好。
Both Rue and Ned moved into this house hoping it would be the last place where they'd ever unpack. Ned got his wish, but if he survives for more than another year, a strong possibility, Rue will have to move out. Her two small rooms will become too small once her baby starts to crawl. For now, though, Rue's proud that the five souls living under her roof are getting along so well. And when Ned finally does die, she says she'll be sad. Along with twinges of wickedness, it's a sadness she bought along with the house.
露和奈德搬进这房子时，都希望能这是他们最后一次拆开行李。奈德如愿以偿，但如果他再多活一年——这可能性很大——露就不得不搬走。一旦她的孩子开始爬行，她的两个小房间就会显得太挤了。但现在，露为她屋檐下生活的五个灵魂相处得如此融洽感到自豪。当奈德最终去世时，她说她会感到难过。伴随着邪恶的刺痛，这也是她买下这房子时一同买下的悲伤。
[PIANO PLAYING]
（钢琴演奏）
There you have my Rachmaninoff period.
这就是我的拉赫玛尼诺夫时期。
Sarah Koenig is one of the producers of our program, and also, incidentally, the host of Serial. We first broadcast this story fourteen years ago, and despite everybody's predictions, Ned and Rue continued to live together in that house for another nine years. They became good friends, they stayed close, until Ned died, finally, in 2009.
萨拉·凯尼格是我们节目的制片人之一，顺便说一下，她还是《Serial》的主持人。我们十四年前首次播出了这个故事，尽管所有人都做出了预测，奈德和露又在那个房子里共同生活了九年。他们成为了好朋友，保持着亲密关系，直到奈德最终在2009年去世。
[MUSIC - THE LOVE NEST, BY THE HI LO'S]
（音乐 - The Hi-Lo's的《爱情窝》）
Act Four, One Word: Timing. This is the story of a joke that would not die. Tami Sagher had just gotten this job that she really wanted, and she was in that position where she was working with people who she really, really respected, and she wanted them to like her. And this job was something that she had never done before. It was to write a script for a television show, to write a situation comedy. And she had finished her first draft, and they had this meeting to go through the draft with her and tell her what changes they wanted. And this is the very first time they were reviewing her work, and she tape-recorded the meeting, so she would get all of their comments, all of their notes, not lose anything.
第四幕，《一个词：时机》。这是一个挥之不去的笑话的故事。塔米·萨格（Tami Sagher）刚刚得到了她梦寐以求的工作，她正处于这样一个职位，与她非常、非常尊敬的人一起工作，她希望他们能喜欢她。这项工作是她以前从未做过的。它是为电视节目写剧本，写一部情景喜剧。她已经完成了初稿，他们有一个会议来审核草稿，告诉她想要什么修改。这是他们第一次审核她的作品，她录下了会议，这样她就能得到他们所有的评价、所有的笔记，不会遗漏任何东西。
And they get to the end of going through the script, and then everybody's still sitting around, and they start making small talk, and it's the two people who run this TV show, and the comedian who is the star of the TV show, this guy Louie C.K., incredibly funny guy. In fact, they're all really funny. And somehow politics comes up, and the three guys in the room are talking about it, being funny, and Tami is just trying to think of something interesting to say. We've all been in the situation at work, or socially, or wherever, she wants to say something funny and smart, and time is passing. And she's getting a little anxious.
审核剧本结束了，大家还坐在那儿，他们开始闲聊。那是负责这部电视节目的两个人，还有那部电视节目的明星喜剧演员——路易·CK（Louie C.K.），一个极其有趣的人。事实上，他们都很有趣。不知怎么的，话题谈到了政治，房间里的三个家伙在谈论它，表现得非常幽默，而塔米只是在努力想些有趣的话说。我们都经历过那种在工作中、社交中，无论哪里，她想说些幽默聪明的话，但时间在流逝。她开始感到有点焦虑。
I'm just scared that it's going to end on this note of them having this really sparkling political debate with funniness, and then like, all right, Tami, go home and write your episode, see you later.
我只是害怕它会以他们进行一场真正闪闪发光的、风趣的政治辩论结束，然后，好吧，塔米，回家写你的剧集吧，下次见。
Right, and you won't get a chance to prove to them that you are one of them?
对，而你没有机会向他们证明你是他们中的一员？
Yeah.
是的。
Just listening to the recording of it, what you sent us, it seems like you're trying to get a word in edgewise, and maybe not always succeeding. But let's play a cut of that.
听着你录的那些，你发给我们的，看起来你是在努力插话，但可能并不总能成功。我们播放一段录音。
And that's where we belong.
而那才是我们所属的地方。
Right.
对。
Or--
或者——
And then the dream is over.
然后梦就醒了。
Or. You're about to go somewhere with that, and you don't really do that. Here's another one.
或者。你本来要用那个去某个地方，但你没真做。再来一个。
Maybe one--
也许一个——
And apart from another Republican President.
除了另一个共和党总统之外。
You can just hear-- like it's a person trying to get on a highway at the ramp, and that sort of like, can I merge? No? OK, OK.
你可以听到——就像一个人试图从坡道进入高速公路，那种感觉，“我可以合并吗？不？好吧，好的。”
So what happens?
那么发生了什么？
OK, so to really get what happens next, you have to know that, four or five years ago, I came up with this joke while I was walking my dog about Ralph Nader. Ralph Nader, like, four years ago said, that 9/11 wouldn't have happened if he'd been elected president, because he would have done something to the cockpit doors as soon as he was elected that would have prevented it from happening.
好吧，要真正理解接下来发生了什么，你必须知道，四五年前，我在遛狗时想出了一个关于拉尔夫·纳德（Ralph Nader）的笑话。拉尔夫·纳德，大概四年前说，如果他当选总统，9/11就不会发生，因为一旦当选，他就会对驾驶舱门做些什么，防止这种事发生。
Right, his group, Public Citizen, had been lobbying to actually strengthen the cockpit doors so nobody can bust into the cockpit doors, but nobody listened to them, basically.
对，他的组织，“公众公民”（Public Citizen），一直在游说加强驾驶舱门，这样没人能闯进去，但基本上没人听他们的。
Exactly. Exactly. And so, when he said that, I came up with a line about it while I was walking my dogs, but I don't do stand-up. But it's a total stand-up line. And so I never actually said the line, because it's sort of impossible to toss off in conversation. And so it just was there. It was just sitting there.
正是如此。正是如此。所以，当他那样说时，我在遛狗时想出了一句关于它的台词，但我不是讲脱口秀的。但那是一句绝对的脱口秀台词。所以我从来没真说过那句台词，因为它在对话中有点难以抛出。所以它就在那儿。它就在那儿搁着。
So you have this four-year-old joke that really has nowhere to live?
所以你有一个放了四年的笑话，根本没地方施展？
Right, and has never been said. And then Louie brings up Ralph Nader.
对，而且从未被说出来。然后路易提到了拉尔夫·纳德。
I voted for Nader in 2000, or whichever one. Yeah, 2000.
我在2000年投票给了纳德，或者不管哪一次。是的，2000年。
What he does is he basically talks about the fact that he voted for Nader, and what people said to him about it. And while he's talking about this, what are you thinking?
他所做的基本上是在谈论他投票给纳德这件事，以及人们对他说了什么。当他谈论这个时，你在想什么？
All I'm thinking is, how can I bring up the cockpit door thing? That's really all I'm thinking.
我心里想的全是，我怎么才能把驾驶舱门那件事提出来？这就是我心里全部的想法。
Can I bring this around to 9/11, so I can say this joke.
我能把这个话题转到9/11吗，这样我就可以讲这个笑话了。
Exactly. But in the meantime, they're talking about other stuff about Ralph Nader, and then I'm sort of biting my tongue, and then Louie brings up the thing about the 9/11 and the cockpit doors. And all of a sudden, there's this organic opening for this line.
正是。但与此同时，他们在谈论关于拉尔夫·纳德的其他事情，然后我有点咬住舌头，然后路易提到了关于9/11和驾驶舱门的事情。突然间，有了一个有机的切入点来引入这句台词。
No, it's like somebody said to Ralph Nader after 9/11, what if that had been you in the White House? Wouldn't even you say now that we wouldn't want Ralph Nader in the White House after 9/11? And he said, sorry, but my organization has been trying to get the airlines to bolt their doors.
不，就像有人在9/11后对拉尔夫·纳德说，如果当时在白宫的是你呢？难道连你现在也会说在9/11之后我们不希望拉尔夫·纳德入主白宫吗？他说，抱歉，但我所在的组织一直在试图让航空公司锁好他们的舱门。
Yeah, he said 9/11 wouldn't have happened--
是的，他说如果我是总统，9/11就不会发生。
Wouldn't have happened if I was president.
就不会发生。
I am thinking, just wait, just wait. Let him do it, let him do it. And then he's not quite getting it out, so I'm kind of like trying to help it along, like just maybe walking into a pitch, like c'mon, here we go baby.
我心里想，等一下，等一下。让他讲出来，让他讲出来。然后他没完全说出来，所以我有点像在帮忙推一把，就像走进投球，就像，得了吧，来吧宝贝。
Because you know if you can just get this out, you are sitting on pure gold. You're sitting on this thing, and finally.
因为你知道如果你能把这个说出来，你就坐在纯金之上。你坐在那东西上，终于。
Yeah. It's had four years to hatch.
是的。它已经酝酿了四年了。
And the federal government won't enforce them.
而联邦政府拒绝执行。
If he'd been elected, he would have been too distracted by all the flying pigs. [LAUGHTER] Come on. Come on.
如果他当选，他会因为所有的飞猪而分心。（笑声）得了吧。得了吧。
It's so sweet. And then they even riff on it for a little while, which is like the best thing that can happen. I think Aaron is doing other sort of hell freezing over jokes.
真是太甜美了。然后他们甚至就此进行了一阵即兴发挥，这是可能发生的最好的事情。我认为亚伦正在讲其他类似于“地狱结冰”之类的笑话。
We wouldn't be spending all our money heating hell.
我们不用把钱全花在给地狱供暖上。
And so for you, did you feel a sense of triumph? Or did you feel instantly a sense that it doesn't count, because you were using a joke that you had made up four years ago?
所以对你来说，你感到了一种胜利感吗？还是你瞬间感到了一种它不作数的感觉，因为你用了一个你四年前编好的笑话？
I felt a total sense of triumph. Well, I felt, like, a 95% sense of triumph, and then a 5%, but it's a lie. And then, whatever, yeah, so's makeup. Makeup is a lie.
我感到了一种完全的胜利感。好吧，我感到了一种95%的胜利感，然后5%的，“但这是个谎言”。然后，管他呢，是的，化妆也是。化妆也是谎言。
And so are you done? Are you in? Is that it? That's it, you used that joke to kind of get you over the hump, and now is it through?
所以你做到了？你成功了？就这样？就是这样，你用那个笑话把你带过了坎，现在这就完了？
I felt like I'm more in, yeah. I don't know that I'll ever feel like I'm in with anybody. But no, I have felt like I'm more in. I have felt a marked difference. I mean, do you ever feel like you're totally in with anybody?
我觉得我更“进入”了，是的。我不知道我是否会觉得自己和任何人“完全进入”。但不，我觉得我更进入了。我感觉到了明显的不同。我的意思是，你有没有感觉自己和任何人“完全进入”？
Dude, I'm married to somebody who I feel like I'm constantly in a situation of having-- she doesn't feel this way, but I totally feel like every day I have to prove myself anew.
伙计，我娶了一个人，我觉得我一直处于需要——她并不这么觉得，但我完全觉得每一天我都要重新证明自己。
Really? Well, here's one more thing though that is kind of sucky about it, though, is by constantly checking in with what the other person's opinion of you is, you're not just being with that person. There's a level of removal there that is sad.
真的吗？嗯，还有一件事虽然关于它有点糟糕，但通过不断检查对方对你的看法，你不仅仅是和那个人在一起。这里有一种疏离感，很悲伤。
Totally. That's totally my personality. For me, I think that something went wrong when I was a kid, where I think that other people, they just accept that they're in. They accept that this other person likes them, and they don't have to keep proving themself. Whereas for me, it's entirely temporal. I'm constantly judging the whole thing moment by moment, and it could always fall apart. For me, it never ends.
完全是。那完全是我的性格。对我来说，我认为当我还是个孩子时有些事出错了，我认为其他人，他们只是接受了他们是“进入”了。他们接受对方喜欢他们，他们不必一直证明自己。而对于我，它是完全短暂的。我时刻都在逐个时刻判断整件事，它随时可能分崩离析。对我来说，它永远不会结束。
I remember when I was a kid, and I think I was probably, like, four maybe, so my sister was nine, and my brother was 14, and we were doing bits around the table. I remember them acting stuff out that I didn't quite understand what was going on. And I remember going up and trying to imitate them, and acting something out. And I remember only my mom laughing. And I remember even then being like, she's just trying to make me feel better, and just knowing it wasn't a real laugh.
我记得当我还是个孩子时，大概四岁吧，我姐姐九岁，我哥哥14岁，我们在餐桌旁讲故事。我记得他们在演一些我不太理解发生了什么的戏。我记得我走过去，试图模仿他们，表演一些东西。我记得只有我妈妈笑了。我记得即使那时我心里也想，她只是想让我感觉好点，我知道那不是真正的笑。
Tough room. [LAUGHTER]
冷场的表演。（笑声）
And also, I was the jerk, too, like whatever Mom, I don't want your unconditional love. Give me some of that-- my father has actually said to me, doesn't my approval mean more because it is conditional? I once was on stage. They asked for a volunteer, and this guy put a blindfold on me, and he danced me around the stage, and all this stuff. And at the end, they take the blindfold off, and they said, how about applause for the volunteer? And everybody in the audience clapped except for my father. And afterwards, I was like, Papa, what's up?  And he goes, you didn't do anything. You were a human prop. What?
而且，我当时也是个混蛋，就像“管他呢妈妈，我不要你那种无条件的爱。给我来点那样的——”我父亲甚至对我说过，难道我的认可不是因为有条件才更有意义吗？有一次我在台上。他们要求一名志愿者，那个人给我蒙上眼睛，他带我在台上跳舞，还有所有那些事。最后，他们拿掉眼罩，他们说，给这位志愿者鼓掌怎么样？观众里的每个人都鼓掌了，除了我父亲。之后我问，爸爸，怎么了？他说，你什么也没做。你只是个活道具。什么？
Tami Sagher. She now writes for the NBC show, 30 Rock . She says that having a storeroom of old jokes, used and unused, inside of her head, sometimes very great and useful, other times, does not serve her so well. A quick warning to listeners in what she's about to say. The jokes that she is about to tell, they aren't explicit or anything, but they might not be appropriate for children.
塔米·萨格。她现在为NBC的《我为喜剧狂》（30 Rock）写剧本。她说，脑子里装满用过和没用过的老笑话，有时非常好用，其他时候，并不怎么帮得上她。给听众一个关于她接下来要说的内容的快速警告。她要讲的笑话，不算露骨什么的，但可能不适合儿童。
I was on a trip to Switzerland, and I was with 18 people. It was one of these walking tours. And this hotel in Switzerland, somebody says, hey, the professional has a joke. And nobody knows me in this group. We've been together two or three days, and the average age is, like, 60-something. And I was about to tell my favorite child molester joke, which is, did you hear about the Jewish pedophile? He's the one who says, hey, kids, easy on the candy. So in my head, I was like, I can't tell the Jewish pedophile joke, because I'm Jewish, so I can say that. But we're in Switzerland, and there's already weirdness there.
我当时在瑞士旅行，和18个人在一起。那是那种步行旅游之一。瑞士的这个旅馆，有人说，嘿，这个专业人士有个笑话。这个小组里没人认识我。我们在一起两三天了，平均年龄大概60多岁。我正要讲我最喜欢的恋童癖笑话，那就是：你听说过犹太恋童癖吗？就是那种会说“嘿，孩子们，少吃点糖”的那个。所以我在脑子里想，我不能讲那个犹太恋童癖笑话，因为我是犹太人，所以我可以讲那个。但我们在瑞士，那里已经有点奇怪的感觉了。
But at the same time, this group is cool enough. So I tell this other child molester joke, which is that a little boy and a child molester are walking through the forest. And all of a sudden, I can just feel the temperature of the table just go down, like, 10 degrees. And one woman goes, oh. And then I'm like, no, I got to go through with it. I'm going to win them over. And so I was like, it's literally a dark and stormy night, and the little boy says I'm scared. And the child molester says, you're scared? I got to walk out of here by myself. And total silence, like total horrible, horrible silence.
但同时，这个小组足够酷。所以我讲了另一个恋童癖笑话，就是一个小男孩和一个恋童癖者走在森林里。突然间，我能感觉到桌子的温度下降了10度。一个女人说，“哦”。然后我想，不，我必须坚持下去。我要赢得他们。所以我说，“那真的是一个风雨交加的夜晚，小男孩说我很害怕。恋童癖说，你害怕？我得一个人走出去。”完全沉默，就像完全可怕、可怕的沉默。
And then the guy down at the end of the table, the one who says, hey, the professional has a joke, now he goes, what do you call a cow that doesn't give any milk? A milk dud. And [CHEERING] we love you, like hilarious joke. And that was just-- It's like a Dixie Cup joke. But totally pandering, because we are in Switzerland, so we're around a lot of cows. And here's my other problem with that joke. It's like nine words long, and he says milk in the question and the answer.
然后桌子那头的家伙，那个说“嘿，专业人士有个笑话”的人，现在他说，“你管不产奶的牛叫什么？牛奶杜德（Milk Dud）。”然后（欢呼）我们爱你，就像滑稽的笑话。那简直就是——就像那种纸杯笑话。但完全是迎合，因为我们在瑞士，所以我们周围有很多牛。这就是我对那个笑话的另一个问题。它只有九个字长，而且他在问题和答案里都说了“牛奶”。
I was thinking of that.
我也在想那个。
Exactly. That's a really poorly phrased joke. It's a low-level joke. Huge laughs, compliments to him. And I'm sitting stewing in the corner, like whatever, a little bit mad even. But my favorite joke, and this is what I always say when people are like, oh, you're in comedy? Tell me a joke. And this always disappoints, always, but I still love it, is, what did the snail say on the turtle's back? Wheeee. Are they're just like, oh, that's what you do for a living? And then I want to be like, no, but you can't handle the truth. You can't handle the Jewish pedophile.
正是。那是一个表达非常差劲的笑话。是一个低级笑话。巨大的笑声，人们称赞他。而我坐在角落里生闷气，管他呢，甚至还有点生气。但我最喜欢的笑话——每当人们说“哦，你是做喜剧的？给我讲个笑话。”时我总是这么说，而这总是让人失望，总是，但我还是喜欢它——是什么蜗牛在乌龟背上说什么？“呜呼！”人们只是觉得，“哦，这就是你赖以生存的？”然后我想说，不，但你无法承受真相。你无法承受犹太恋童癖。
Well, our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Jane Feltes, Lisa Pollack, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Shiow-Jiau Yung runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind, Bruce Wallace, music help from Jessica Hopper.
好吧，我们的节目今天由萨拉·凯尼格和我本人制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、黛安·库克（Diane Cook）、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）、丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollack）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。萧娇云（Shiow-Jiau Yung）管理我们的网站。制作帮助来自塞思·林德（Seth Lind）、布鲁斯·华莱士（Bruce Wallace），音乐帮助来自杰西卡·霍珀（Jessica Hopper）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（鸣谢）
Our website, where you can get our free weekly podcasts, or listen to our old shows for free, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，在那里您可以获得我们每周的免费播客，或免费收听我们以前的节目，www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（资助鸣谢）
WBEZ management oversight for our program, Mr. Torey Malatia, who does not understand why we did Act Four today, no matter what I say.
我们节目的WBEZ管理监督是托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生，无论我怎么说，他都不明白我们为什么今天要播第四幕。
So basically, you're saying it's an inexplicable act, and it happened for no real reason at all?
所以基本上，你是在说这是一种无法解释的行为，而且它发生时根本没有任何真正的理由？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多这些美国生活的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。